This video was made possible by Brilliant.
Learn to think like a scientist for 20% off
by
being one of the first 500 people to sign
up at the link in the description.
Nuclear energy is one of the cleanest, most
efficient, and most available sources of power
on earth.
To generate one kilowatt hour of energy—the
amount an American household
consumes in 48 minutes—nuclear power plants
only emit 12 grams of carbon dioxide— enough
to fill about three two-liter soda bottles.
Meanwhile, to produce the same amount of energy,
coal
plants emit 820 grams of CO2—about a full
bathtub’s worth.
Factoring in the environmental cost
of production, nuclear energy is cleaner than
hydropower, than geothermal, than solar, than
really
any energy source except wind.
But that doesn’t necessarily mean nuclear
is the long-term
solution for the world because nuclear material
is perhaps the most poisonous substance on
earth.
Two times in history have nuclear power plants
leaked significant amount of radiation—in
in Chernobyl, Ukraine and in 2011 in Fukushima,
Japan.
31 people died in Chernobyl with at
least a further 4,000 expected to contract
early lethal cancer due to the radiation.
Fukushima was
better contained with only two deaths, both
unrelated to radiation, and only 130 early
cancer
deaths expected, but additionally, each site
still today has massive exclusion zones where
humans cannot live due to ongoing radiation.
Hundreds of thousands of people were displaced
from their homes and will never be allowed
to return.
The economic damage of Chernobyl is
estimated at nearly $250 billion dollars—significantly
more than the GDP of Ukraine.
The
Fukushima disaster, meanwhile, having taken
place is a much more populated and developed
area, is estimated to set Japan back over
$500 billion dollars—a full 10% of their
GDP.
In
addition, uranium, the element most commonly
used in nuclear reactors, is not in limitless
supply.
Using present-day extraction methods, there’s
only about a 230 year supply of uranium
left.
Many would say nuclear is only a short-term
solution to reduce carbon emissions until
truly
sustainable energy can become commonplace,
but the biggest problem with nuclear energy
is not
the risk of meltdown, it’s not the supply
of uranium, it’s this—nuclear waste.
All current commercial nuclear power plants
work through the process of nuclear fission.
As a radioactive element decays, the individuals
atoms split into multiple, but when that happens
the reaction also releases energy.
There are plenty of different designs of nuclear
reactors, but in
general they capture the released energy by
using it to heat up water into steam which
runs
through turbines that spin generators.
The nuclear element used is typically uranium
which, after
about six to eight years of usage in a nuclear
power plant will have released enough of its
energy
that it is no longer useful in nuclear reactors,
but that doesn’t mean it’s done emitting
energy.
The
fuel rods will remain radioactive enough to
emit a lethal dose for tens or hundreds of
thousands
of years past their removal.
So the question is, what do you do with them?
The answer is simple—put them somewhere
where they can stay, undisturbed, isolated,
forever, but that’s not all that easy.
In fact, no nuclear waste worldwide is currently
in what is
considered long-term storage.
Every bit of nuclear waste in existence is
in temporary storage
facilities to be used until a long-term solution
is built.
Most of that nuclear waste is stored in pools
of water.
Water does a decently good job of
shielding radiation so this is an inexpensive
and easy way of storing the rods.
Usually these pools
are physically inside the nuclear power plants
so, when spent fuel is removed from the reactor,
it’s put directly into the water and left
there.
The radioactive material, since it’s still
emitting
energy, continues to heat up the water, but
cooling systems and pumps keep the water below
boiling temperature, but to do that the plant
needs power.
If the power fails and the backup
generators fail, the pumps and cooling systems
stop working so the water heats up and can
boil
off.
The water is what blocks the radiation so,
without water, the radiation just goes right
out into
the environment.
In fact, exactly that happened at Fukushima.
Both the primary and backup
power sources failed so the pumps and cooling
systems for the spent fuel pools couldn’t
run
leaving the water to heat up.
The situation was brought under control before
enough water had
boiled off to release significant amounts
of radiation into the environment, but had
it not been,
thousands could have been killed.
Once nuclear waste has cooled down in storage
pools for ten to twenty years, it typically
is encased in casks.
These concrete and steel containers block
in radiation, but this solution is far
from permanent.
It does not consider earthquakes, it cannot
withstand tsunamis, and it would not
work without humans.
These casks require security and they require
maintenance.
Without
humans, they could easily be damaged or breached
over time and release radiation into the
environment.
Modern humans have only existed for about
200,000 years, so one can hardly be
sure that the species will survive for the
millions of years that the most toxic nuclear
waste will
continue to emit radiation.
What’s more, one can hardly expect that
the dominant civilizations
that have nuclear technology today will continue
to exist for even thousands of years.
The
Roman Empire was once without a doubt the
most powerful civilization on earth.
Scholars even
believe that it is the most powerful civilization
to have ever existed on earth—more powerful
than the US, than Europe, than any modern
civilization, but it fell, and so too will
the west.
Therefore, long-term nuclear waste storage
needs to last longer than any political structure,
it
needs to work without the supervision of humans,
it needs to be truly and unequivocally
permanent.
Finland is building just that.
This region is largely devoid of natural disasters.
It doesn’t
have earthquakes, it doesn’t see tsunamis,
it really doesn’t encounter any natural
phenomenon
that could damage a nuclear waste storage
site, especially if it’s 1,500 feet underground.
Beneath
an island on the Finnish Baltic Sea coast,
the country is digging.
They’re building the very first
permanent nuclear waste storage facility in
the world in the stable bedrock 1,500 feet
below.
Currently they’re just finishing their dig
down then very soon, in 2020, they’ll start
filling the
facility with nuclear waste.
They’ll dig long tunnels with small holes
in which they’ll place casks
of nuclear waste then backfill the tunnels
with clay to be left for an eternity.
With this system,
there’s near zero risk of nuclear material
leaking out into the groundwater and, once
it’s filled in
the year 2120, it can just be left, forever.
Because the material will be so far down and
so
difficult to get to, no human management will
be necessary once completed.
No security, no
maintenance, nothing which means it should
be truly secure, but before leaving it, they
do need
to fight against one thing—human nature.
As curious beings, it’s hard to combat a
person’s urge of discovery.
If someone finds a
mysterious structure from thousands of years
ago, it’d just be natural to want to open
it up, and
that’s a problem for nuclear waste sites.
We essentially did just that with the pyramids
in Egypt.
These structures were built as the final,
permanent resting places for the elites of
Egypt and we
opened them up because we were curious.
Opening the nuclear storage facilities would
release
radiation into a future civilization, so we
have to tell them to leave the sites alone,
but that’s
easier said than done.
The US Department of Energy commissioned a
study on how to communicate the danger
into the far future.
The key is to create a message that conveys
how uninteresting, how
unimportant, and how dangerous nuclear waste
is.
They settled on the following text:
Sending this message was important to us.
We considered ourselves to be
a powerful culture.
This place is not a place of honor…
no highly esteemed deed
is commemorated here… nothing valued is
here.
What is here was dangerous and
repulsive to us.
This message is a warning about danger.
The danger is in a
particular location…
it increases toward a center… the center
of danger is here...
of a particular size and shape, and below
us.
The danger is still present, in your
time, as it was in ours.
The danger is to the body, and it can kill.
The form of the
danger is an emanation of energy.
The danger is unleashed only if you
substantially disturb this place physically.
This place is best shunned and left
uninhabited.
The idea would be to translate a message like
this into every United Nations language—
Arabic, Chinese, English, French, Russian,
and Spanish.
There’s a reasonable hope that, at least
in the next couple thousand years, one of
those languages would be understood.
But in the scope
of hundreds of thousands of years, there’s
just little expectation that these languages
would
survive.
There’s not even a reasonable expectation
that humans would survive.
So, you need to
convey the same message without language.
What the study suggests is to further push
the message by building a landscape that
conveys danger.
It could be a scene of thorns, or spikes,
or forbidding blocks.
To satiate the
discoverer’s curiosity, it’s also suggested
to add monoliths explaining the history of
the site
through pictographs.
Also included would be images like this, engraved
in stone, conveying that
the substance has danger that will be passed
onto humans if touched, but the difficulty
of this is
that it very well might not be humans exploring
earth 100,000 years from now.
It could be a
species that doesn’t recognize the likeness
of what might be a long-extinct species.
What some have suggested is to just let the
site be forgotten, to not mark it at all,
to just
seal it up, and leave, but having something
that significant disappear isn’t simple.
The site in
Finland is designed to not need security or
oversight, but its current location is very
well
documented in a potentially irreversible way.
With books and brains and the internet, records
of
the site might exist until at least the end
of human civilization.
To truly be forgotten, to truly be
left as part of nature, so too must humans
be forgotten.
If you want to learn more about clean energy
or anything else, you should try Brilliant.
They have a fantastic course on solar energy
complete with approachable explanations,
straightforward graphics, and thought-provoking
puzzles.
I’ve really been enjoying Brilliant
because their courses do a great job of providing
an overview of complex topics in a way that
anyone can understand.
As a Wendover Productions viewer who enjoys
learning or is serious
about science, Brilliant’s interactive puzzles
will help you explore all kinds of interesting
stuff.
If
you want to check them out, head over to brilliant.org/Wendover.
The first 500 who do and sign
up will receive 20% off.
I absolutely suggest that you give Brilliant
a try because it’s truly a great
website and doing so helps make Wendover Productions
possible.